on va aller
patricia va subir un bypass une
réduction de l'estomac pour perdre du
poids
l'opération sera réalisée avec le robot
da vinci's
[Musique]
tout ça c'est impressionnant rapport à
quatre bras articulé portant des
instruments miniaturisés assisté par
microprocesseur sont plongés dans le
ventre de la patiente à travers de
minuscules une incision
[Musique]
le robot est en place les marais on
contrôle la
fonctionnalité et le placement des bras
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'interférence
que ça ne pointe pas pendant
l'intervention
puis après une fois qu'il est mis en
place j'ai l'aide qui reste sur le champ
opératoire
et puis moi je me mets sur la console
pour faire vraiment l'intervention
programmée
très bien
à voir cette coordination visuel entre
les convois sur en 3d et les la
gestuelle qu'on est en train d'appliquer
donc c'est pas aussi simple que les jeux
vidéo et c'est surtout qu'on n'a pas
droit à l'erreur sur sa console
le chirurgien bénéficie d'une vue
agrandie en trois dimensions comme s'il
était lui-même à l'intérieur de la
patiente
il peut effectuer des rotations
impossible pour la main humaine là sur
les fils si je tiens trop fort ça me
casse donc tout ça c'est avec
l'expérience qu'on évalue la force à
appliquer sur les tissus et les films le
robot il a donné aux chirurgiens de
pouvoir le contrôle total du champ
opératoire jeu contrôler la caméra je
contrôle l'exposition je contrôle les
gestes je contrôle la dissection et j'ai
besoin juste d'une personne qualifiée
sur le champ opératoire
au départ la chirurgie robotique est
issue d'une coopération entre la nasa et
l'armée américaine pour opérer les
soldes à distance sur les théâtres de
guerre
les militaires ont renoncé mais des
ingénieurs du hem haïti de boston ont
racheté les deux revers il y a cinq ans
l'hôpital d'orléans a décidé de miser
gros sur la robotique
aujourd'hui les plus grands spécialistes
français et belges de chirurgie
abdominale assiste en direct à une
opération de l'estomac pratiquer avec le
robot hal étage juste au dessus pendant
ce temps dans le hall
certains découvrent les plaisirs de la
console
[Musique]
sa première fois que j'utilise parce
qu'on est à construire on en a pas là
quelques minutes c'est pas difficile de
pouvoir s'adapter
le chu de nancy forme les médecins qui
veulent passer de la coelioscopie une
technique mini invasive à la chirurgie
robotisée
on reçoit des chirurgiens d'expériences
différentes dans notre centre de
simulation et on voit qu'il ya quand
même
des fosses très différente ou peut être
un très bon coelioscopie et avoir
beaucoup de mal à intégrer la façon de
faire avec le robot parce que la
gestuelle est quand même très
différentes
on est à distance du patient et puis
vous avez d'autres chirurgiens qui
n'était pas déçu de ce caucus
l'expérimenté qui très vite vont adhérer
à la machine l'hôpital d'orléans qui a
acquis cette année deux robots de
dernière génération forme sur place le
personnel infirmier exactement vu qu'il
situe sera stérile
là tu peux menthe et d ici soit on
articulations n'hésite pas vas-y vas-y
vas-y approche trop malaxe voilà et tout
en parallèle c'est vrai que les débuts
c'est une gestuelle à apprendre parce
que c'est pas assez totalement différent
de la celio et donc effectivement on a
quand même une certaine appréhension
le fait d'être tout seul le chirurgien à
la console quoi mais c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas le laisser d'emblée tout seul
on a toujours redire des seniors avec
nous pour là pour nous aider quoi une
guide et on a un optique qui semble à
peu près identique à celui des six du
conflit mais qui lui possède en fait non
pas une mais deux caméras messi et qui
permettent la vision en trois dimensions
je suis au japon sur nous encore plus
que dans n'importe quelle discipline
les infirmiers interagissent où il ya
vraiment un travail d'équipé de
confiance une relation confiance qui
s'installe entre le chirurgien et
l'infirmier l'infirmière de bloc
opératoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'arrivée du robot a aussi renforcé
l'attractivité de l'hôpital en attirant
de jeunes médecins
c'est le cas du docteur dussart il
réalise sa 20e opération robotisée
l'ablation d'une tumeur cancéreuse qui
nécessitent d'enlever une partie de
l'estomac et de lezo fages
une intervention lourde et complexe
l'objectif c'est de retirer toutes les
cellules qui sont potentiellement sortie
de la tumeur et qui sont partis dans les
ganglions qui draine l'organe
donc là on a une vision c'est quasi la
micro chien de la microscopique
chirurgicale on est vraiment centré sur
la zone que je veux auquel je veux
retirer les gants millions le robot a
convaincu aussi les anesthésistes
c'est un outil dans l'irruption a changé
beaucoup de choses en milieu opératoire
il permet de ma vision de médecin
anesthésiste de faire en sorte que les
patients aient une agression minimes moi
je suis là pour traquer le traumatisme
chirurgicale et dont si l'agression
minimes les gens moins mal après
et c'est pour moi l'essentiel
une semaine après l'intervention le
docteur dussart rend visite à son
patient
ça va pas trop de douleur donc ça s'est
bien passé
il ya juste eu des douleurs pour les
côtes le vendre bike douleur leur nom
les côtes coiffures à tresse illustré
c'est choquant ses proches moi je
reproche le corps
[Musique]
dans quel sens qu'est ce que vous avez
repensé dans un autre monde
ah oui oui le robot n'y aurait-il que
des avantages
pas si sûr la société américaine
intuitive qui le fabrique n'a pour
l'instant pas de concurrent
cette position hégémonique a un coût
pour les établissements 2 millions
d'euros par robot 150000 euros de
maintenance parents et les opérations
avec davinci son tarif est comme les
autres
un investissement que justifie pourtant
le directeur de l'hôpital d'orléans et
on s'est aperçu que pôle de chirurgie
avait contribué deux au moins autant que
les autres retour à l'équilibré d'une
part en faisant progresser son activité
notamment grâce au robot mais aussi en
réduisant ses coûts sur le pôle de
chirurgie a réussi à faire des économies
malgré l'acquisition du robot qui comme
vous l'avez soucis et coûte cher en
fonctionnement mais par ailleurs sur
d'autres postes de dépenses le pôle de
chirurgie a fait des économies parce que
les équipes se sont mobilisées tout
simplement parce qu'elles ont envie de
réussir ce projet robot
sur le plan médical rien ne prouve que
l'on a plus de chance de guérison en
étant opérée avec un robot des études
sont en cours mais la plus grande
clinique de france lyon médipôle a déjà
fait marche arrière
finalement vous de 28 mois on s'est dit
qu'elle est l'intérêt pour le patient
est en fait pour le patient s'est aperçu
qu'il n'y avait pas un intérêt majeur
c'est à dire que le patient ne sortait
pas plus vite qu'avec une coelioscopie
que la durée opératoire était parfois
plus longues que par coelioscopie et que
finalement pour l'établissement y avait
pas un coup il n'y avait pas de soulever
un avantage qui était qu'ils étaient
supérieurs des doutes les équipe
orléanaise non non pas grâce au robot
le ch héros occupe une place de leader
régional voire national
et par les temps qui courent ça n'a pas
de prix car un tel gain en termes
d'envergure internationale de
publications scientifiques de
positionnement régional parce que c'est
un des vrais enjeux là je discutais avec
un chirurgien de châteauroux qui est
intéressé partir dans nos structures à
cause de ça
grâce à cela et pour nous c'est un
c'est déjà un succès d'arriver à
organiser ça ici il ya dix ans je vous
aurais dit c'est pas possible
ce matin là le docteur ahmad chirurgien
à vierzon va insister à l'ablation d'une
prostate cancéreux sur l'un de ses
patients c'est le docteur ramal
spécialistes or les années du robot qui
va réaliser l'opération
voilà donc ça c'est le cas mais rares à
l'est de coincer et c'est au plein et
par la suite
2ème étape c'est de mettre les
instruments se contrôle de vue dans le
ventre de passion
pour ça il y a deux méthodes soit on
laisse couler les muscles soit quand les
gages moi je trouve qu'on dégage et on a
plus de visibilité vraiment qu'on peut
identifier mieux tes films et scolaires
ici tu vois et donc si bien parce que
bon c'est pas une petite prostate chez
lui dans le coup voilà le médecin or les
années propose à son confrère
vierzonnais de découvrir la console et
la vision en 3d laisse quelques secondes
pour tout voir la trois dimensions 1 est
ce que tu vois bien maintenant tu vois
bien maintenant la réalité donc tata
l'école des écarts devant toi d'en
guérir et peut aspirer gaye elle au
niveau du col pour te montrer le col
d'ey ecal
donc je prends les mains maintenant 1 on
va vraiment très loin dans la précision
c'est extrêmement précis en plus
rotation quand 60° cité un peu de la
fiction la science fiction à l'époque et
là sincèrement ça devient réel on en
parle avec un monsieur eddy voilà oui
enlever la prostate à dire c'est un
continent c'est à dire j'aurais de
fuites urinaires et des problèmes
d'érection or c'est faux avec la
robotique
on a montré ça et effectivement on a
gagné beaucoup de points
vous avez là l'exemple devant vous
comment on a pu conserver complètement
cette partie de canal loin de 5 taire
pour ne pas avoir justement des fluides
post opératoire ou bien très peu par
rapport aux autres méthodes surugue ans
en 2018 le centre hospitalier régional
d'orléans a réalisé trois cent soixante
dix opérations robotisée sur 17500 dans
le monde davinci a franchi le cap des 5
millions d'interventions
un chiffre en constante augmentation et
la technologie n'en est qu'à ses débuts
à mon avis dans dix ans ce qui changera
c'est encore moins d'agressivité
vis-à-vis du patient dire que là vous
voyez il ya quatre bras dans dix ans il
y aura qu'un bras
il y aura un petit trou dans le ventre
et peut-être même pas dans le ventre
d'ailleurs et il y aura des instruments
qui se déploieront l'intérieur
les vraisemblablement moi je serais plus
derrière la console 2
à opérer mais j'aurais préparé
l'opération en amont il y aura un
programme qui déroulera l'opération
[Musique]
l'évolution de la chirurgie robotique je
pense qu'elle n'a pas de limites
on n'est pas encore à l'intelligence
artificielle on n'est pas encore à
l'autonomie du robot mais je pense qu'il
ya il faut toujours un chirurgien
présent parce que l'humain n'a pas de
d'équivalent quelle que soit l'évolution
de la technologie faut toujours l'oeil
humain les imprévus si une un robot ci
n'a pas appris l'imprévu qu'il va
rencontrer
il va y vas y vas boguey alors que
l'humain il s'adapte et il sait comment
contourner les difficultés 5000 robots
chirurgicaux sont déployés sur la
planète et le monde militaire suit
toujours de très près leur développement
sera-t-il le meilleur ami de l'homme
il est encore un peu tôt pour le dire